a plastic chip about the size of a
credit card could one day diagnose
disease in the remotest regions of the
developing world so using just one
microliter of whole blood we were able
to get detection of HIV and we can do
that in the field with less volume in
about 15 minutes instead of several
hours the device dubbed the EM chip by
Samuel CNAs team at Columbia University
is designed to work in places without
access to advanced lab facilities
there's no question I think that this
type of test is really needed in the
developing world and appreciate it but
the question is can we actually develop
the test to a point where it can be made
available at a sufficiently low cost to
keep costs low the M chip was designed
with only three simple parts a plastic
tube loaded with blood and chemical
reagents a molded plastic card lined
with micro channels and a syringe that
pulls the blood and reagents through the
device with a team of talented lab mates
we took this exact format to Rwanda
where we did testing on locally
collected patient samples we did testing
for both HIV and syphilis this was a
tests that could be performed less than
20 minutes
with only a finger prick of whole blood
and we had performance that rivaled that
of benchtop laboratory assays and the
microfluidic design is very simple it's
essentially a straight channel a linear
channel that's been looped around in
various ways and then at different parts
of this microfluidic channel we would
have different zones where we would
pattern in a molecule that captures what
you want to detect when whole blood
flows into these loops tones antibodies
against disease proteins become trapped
and then what follows is that you would
have washing reagents secondary
antibodies delivered automatically to
the
detection areas and then at the end
because you have the silver development
reagent that develops into solid silver
if you have the gold nanoparticles
captured on the surface and so the
thickness of the silver film that's
formed reflects the amount of analyte
that was originally in your sample and
then we simply look at how much light
pass through that silver film silver and
gold may sound like expensive materials
but the EM chip is actually quite cheap
the material in making the cassette is
just pennies in plastic and even the
reagents because we use such low volumes
only cost a few pennies but we think
that after packaging it together it will
probably cost a few dollars the next
step is to take the EM chip into mass
production see his team is working with
kleros Diagnostics a company that he
co-founded together with Vincent Linder
the ultimate goal is to bring the
manufacturing of VM chip directly to
those who need it in the developing
world we really tried to keep everything
as simple as possible so the control
alignment which is behind me is actually
something which can be moved in any
location on short notice and all the
equipment inside of it is of the shelf
equipment so we could possibly move the
entire facility anywhere in the world on
short notice and be able to produce the
same quality of material per Thomas
worldwide we are presented one way of
integrating different micro fluidics
technologies together that can be
effective in a very resource limited
setting the most remote regions of the
world the M chip is described in the
August issue of Nature Medicine
you